these guys put together a show for hulu
during the pandemic it's called only
murders in the building and it is the
most watched thing ever on hulu did you
guys know that that it is actually the
most watched comedy metrics comedy
comedy show i think that's right that's
what i've heard but yeah but you don't
have to include that yeah we don't have
to say that yeah the most watched show
not just hulu
but possibly in the world in the world
how did you get the hulu show done so
here's like being being directed on a
coveted set where we finished take one
here comes the director
[Music]
steve when you're writing this you know
you're going to put marty in it right
this was a project for you and martin
with the time of the writing first of
all i had this idea for three old people
in a building
and they they like they just realize
they like true crime but
because they're old they didn't want to
go downtown so they'd say okay only
murders in the building and then there's
a murder in the building i mean what's
amazing about steve
is that he never i mean all this endless
he never gets writer's block
no matter how hard you pray for it it
just doesn't
no it's weird it is it's really quite
something and steve made good use of his
time during the pandemic and came up
with an idea for a show and actually uh
well actually i came up with that way
before the pandemic i had the idea i had
the idea for like 10 years
and what happened was
the idea i just kept it to my mind i
didn't really tell anybody and then when
we're finally i did pitch it to you know
dan fogelman and some great people
and then we had the idea i said well
they said you want to be in it and i
said
oh i i don't i'll do it if marty does it
and that's that's what happened and he
said
you